Mày 12 tháng 6 tại Khi học Thú chính, của hội khoảng 15, các đại biểu đã thảo luận và chính thức thông qua,
đi an sắp nhập đơn vị hành chính cấp tình.
Như vậy, cả nước sẽ có 3 mươi đơn vị hành chính cấp tình,
gồm sấu thành phố chức thuật Trung ương và 2 mì tảm tình.
Tổng biến chế cả một công trước, viên trước theo định mức được rao của các cơ quan,
tổ trước đơn vị cấp tình thuật 5.2 tình thành phố thực hiện sắp sẽ là 4.5 mũi bài nhìn sấu trăm 5.5 mũi bài người.
Mà chăm 6 mũi sấu nhìn 2 chăm mùi tảm viên trước.
Sau sắp sấu lượng cả một công trước, viên trước của cấp tình tối ra không vật quá tổng số cả một.
Công trước, viên trước, số có mặt của cấp tình trước sắp sẽ lồng thời thực hiện tình giản biên chế,
gắn với cơ cấu lại và nước cao chết lượng lội nụ cả một công trước, viên trước,
bảo đảm trong thời hạn năm năm, cơ bản mũi thảo đúng quy đình.
Sau khi cấp tình bị bảo hành động chính phủ sẽ chỉ đạo bộ nội vụ.
Tối hợp với bản tổ chức trung lân các tình quy thành quy trực thuộc trung lân và các cơ quan liên quan
căn cờ quy mô dân số, diện tích tự nhiên chức năng nghiệm vụ, quyên hạn của chính quyền đe phương cấp tình.
Để xây dựng vị chỉ việc làm chính cấp có thầm quyền, rao biên chế cắn vụ.
Công trước, viên trước cho điều phương.
Về phương án sắp sếp, bố chỉ trụ sở tài sản công, tổng số trụ sở công cấp tình của 5.5 mũi thành tháng 4.5 mũi tảm viên mũi chăm tảm viên 2 trụ sở.
số rận trụ sở công dự kến tiếp tục sử dụng, 8 mũi thành trăm là mì sáo trụ sở.
Rồi dự bố nhìn 2 trăm 2 mũi sáo trụ sở.
Rửa đây là quy mô dân số, diện tích, kinh tế của 8 mũi tư tình thành bố sáo sắp nhập.